das kommende rennen hier in berlin ist
in vollem gange und es wird um die
weltmeisterschaft der elektro rennwagen
gekämpft
für diese rennwagen wurden neue
technologien entwickelt und wir sind weg
stage und gucken uns die jetzt mal an
in der renault box treffe ich den
chefentwickler des formel rennwagens
roberto und latsch erklärt dass die
wagen auf formel-3-rennen autos basieren
er zeigt mir hier die verschiedenen
baugruppen wie getriebe und motor
wir haben im moment haben wir noch keine
erfahrung wir mussten bei null anfangen
muss sehen was auf dem markt ist und
davon dass beste auswählen
das zentrum dieses autos ist das
kühlungssystem und das kühlsystem
das ist allein der kühler für die
batterie die brauchen eigenen kühler und
wenn das rennen gefahren worden ist dann
wird dir trockeneis reingesetzt wird
trockeneis hier in die kühlung gemacht
und die rein geblasen um die batterien
zu grünen die nicht über 65 grad heiß
werden dürfen und hier drüben haben ein
weiteres kühlungs bestehen
und das ist nur für den motor da also
the temperature ist big challenge for
you ist die temperatur ist die größte
herausforderung für sie frage ich es ist
eine der größten herausforderungen auch
für die fahrer die energie ist begrenzt
die kraft ist limitiert der fahrer
musste mit spielen und auch die maximale
temperatur der batterien muss er
berücksichtigen sobald er sieht dass die
batterien zu heiß werden muss er die
geschwindigkeit reduzieren
die hälfte bierwirth oder musik an der
spitze sein aber kontinuierlich er muss
alles ausbalancieren
du kannst dich immer höchst sympathisch
das ist ja viel komplizierter als bei
der vollen 120 bewertung
das kann ich nicht sagen es ist anders
so jetzt habe ich hier mal in die kiste
an hier ist das trockeneis drin also
eisig kalt und das ist so kalt bei muss
richtig aufpassen
das ist nämlich so kalt wenn es an einer
stelle an der haut liegen bleibt dann
verbrennt man sich quasi die haut also
durch die eisige kälte wird die haut
zerstört aber mit diesen niedrigen
temperaturen nur damit kriegt man die
akkus in einem temperaturbereich nachdem
das rennen gefahren ist der dafür sorge
trägt dass die auch halten und auch
energie weiterhin abgeben können wenn
sie zu heiß werden
dann geht ihre leistung tierischen den
keller leistung ist auch ein wichtiges
kriterium für die reifen
sie mussten speziell für die formel e
wagen neu entwickelt werden
im gegensatz zu benzin getriebenen
rennwagen steht bei elektro rennwagen
bereits auf den ersten metern der volle
drehmoment zur verfügung die
gummimischung muss deshalb für die
formel härter als für die formel 1 ein
ja durch diese leitung fließt der strom
mit dem die elektro rennwagen geladen
werden
und das ist so wahnsinnig
es gibt wenige baustellen auf der ganzen
welt die so viel strom verbrauchen das
entspricht ungefähr 2000 haushalten
und ja das wird schon erstens ziemlich
warm zweitens man spürt hier richtig den
strom fließen also die 50 yards
wechselstrom und man hört es auf
man spürte so stark dass wenn man sich
darauf stellt dann geht das durch den
ganzen körper also wirklich unglaublich
was er so abläuft und hierher kommt der
strom der chefingenieur von aqua führen
shawn mcneil zeigt uns den container in
dem der diesel generator steht der den
strom produziert allerdings ist dieser
generator besonders umweltfreundlich
wenn man sich da oben das anguckt da
sind die schornsteine leute da kommt
kein co2 aus weil hier wird kein diesel
treibstoff verbrannt sondern agra fuel
und ich werde mich jetzt mal informieren
was es damit auf sich hat technik das
medio also der ersten treibstoff in
meinem leben den ich probiere das ist
jetzt mal fischen to charge us power
will erklärt uns dass diese technologie
sogar effizienter ist als die
herkömmliche stromproduktion er sagt bei
normalem strom wird meistens eine menge
co2 produziert eigentlich genau so viel
wie bei einem herkömmlichen
verbrennungsmotor bei der aqua für
technologie entsteht keinerlei co2
vollkommen neue techniken werden hier
also eingesetzt um die formel 1
weltmeisterschaft überhaupt möglich zu
machen und das hat konsequenzen
neue technologien sind hierbei der
formel entwickelt die inzwischen auch in
die serienproduktion geflossen sind zum
beispiel renault in dieser mission
generation in die 995 patente sind hier
angemeldet worden
der verbrauch wurde deutlich gesenkt und
damit die reichweite gesteigert also es
ist noch eine menge drin bei der
elektromobilität und eine menge drin ist
auch bei der raumfahrt raumfahrt für
alle wenn euch das interessiert klickt
auf dieses video die news von pixum gibt
es im blog in der app dafür hier klicken
alle links natürlich auch in der video
beschreibung und was meint ihr ist es
vernünftig so was wie formel zu machen
also umwelttechnologie
die und autorennen zusammenzubringen
diskutiert es in den kommentaren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt